in baden-württembergischen Tübingen
erhält der Stadtteil Lustnau ein neues
Feuerwehrhaus vor dem Gebäude wird eine
Lärmschutzwand gebaut Kosten 200.000
Euro so sollen die Häuser auf der
gegenüberliegenden Seite vor
lärmgeschützt werden das Ding hilft den
Anwohnern aber rein gar nicht denn
direkt hinter der schönen neuen
Lärmschutzwand verläuft eine
Hauptverkehrsstraße mit täglich mehr als
28.000 Fahrzeugen
ja ich meine das ist einfach unfassbar
also das kann man mit Logik nicht
erklären also das ist ja kontraproduktiv
den Anwohnern gegenüber also die
Lärmschutzwand ist auf jeden Fall
übertrieben sinnlos ich weiß nicht wofür
das nutzen soll wir wohnen auf der
falschen Seite der Lärmschutzmauer weil
nicht die Feuerwehr macht den Lärm
sondern die Autos vor der Feuerwehr
deswegen wäre die Lärmschutzmauer
Richtung Anwohner sinnvoller gewesen
beim neuen Feuerwehrhaus muss geprüft
werden ob durch das Gebäude störende
lärmen mit dies ist bei diesem
Parkplätzen der Fall weil hier die
Feuerwehrleute ihre Autos abstellen und
die Türen zuschlagen muss es für die
Nachbarschaft ein Lärmschutz geben
deshalb muss die Wand gebaut werden so
will es die bundesweite Vorschrift
technische Anleitung lernen dass das
bisschen türenschlagen im Vergleich zum
Straßenlärm völlig irrelevant ist tut
dabei nicht zur Sache damit das Ding
überhaupt eine Wirkung hat hätte man das
eigentlich auf die andere Straßenseite
bauen müssen
soll doch die Schützen die da wohnen und
da muss ja auf der richtigen Seite
gebaut werden Fassungslosigkeit was ist
für Vorschriften hier mittlerweile gibt
die eingehalten werden müssen ohne den
normalen Menschenverstand einzusetzen
und zu schauen ob das nicht irgendwas
bringt oder nicht bringt laut Tübinger
Stadtverwaltung haben man beim Bau gar
keine andere Wahl gehabt
Oberbürgermeister Palmer teilt uns
schriftlich mit mir wurde der
Sachverhalt vorgetragen und wegen der
Dringlichkeit des Bauvorhabens und der
fehlenden Standort Alternative habe ich
zugestimmt obwohl mir die Sinnlosigkeit
der Lärmschutzwand vollständig bewusst
war
dass irgendwas gebaut wird obwohl jeder
weiß dass es unnötig ist können die
Tübinger nicht verstehen so was zu
machen bringt ja gar nichts für die
Anwohner hier und das feuere Haus
braucht man sicherlich nicht vor
irgendwem Schall zu schützen Sinn machen
tut sie glaubt nicht vielleicht andere
Seite wäre besser gewesen wenigstens ein
Zweck erfüllt die teure und sinnlose
Lärmschutzwand die Notrufnummer konnte
so gut montiert werden dass sie jetzt
jeder lesen kann